délivrer la bonne passe est trop soutien
de son coéquipier tout cela sans les
fameux plaquage demandeur d'emploi et
recruteurs ont été plongés dans le monde
du rugby sans savoir qui est qui ils ont
participé à des ateliers notamment des
exercices pour la touche une dizaine
d'ateliers et progressivement ils
apprennent à travailler ensemble autour
de consignes qui sont données par les
techniciens là on fait une touche avec
un sauteur et quatre releveurs donc il
faut vraiment qu'ils apprennent à se
coordonner à travailler ensemble à
sélectionner qui va lever qui va
renvoyer la balle qui va sauter au coeur
de cette journée organisée à montigny le
bretonneux la ligue ile de france de
rugby et pôle emploi des conseillers
pôle emploi mêler aux participants dans
cette agence sportive d'une journée ils
ont pu se faire leur propre avis dans un
schéma atypique tout comme les
demandeurs d'emploi il ya les gens qui
courent sur le ballon qui tombe avec qui
n'ont pas peur de se faire mal y aller
un peu plus timorés un peu plus éloignés
mais les suiveurs y aller les biden les
leaders et puis à un moment donné il ya
des gens qui se révèle qu'ils sont un
peu suiveurs et qui prennent un petit
peu le l'ascendant donc c'est assez
intéressant aussi c'est très bien
surtout pour le niveau social parce
qu'il ya des certaines personnes des
fois ils
sont plutôt renfermés sur eux-mêmes et
peut-être aujourd'hui ça leur a servi de
de ba2 des preuves ça oblige à écouter
les autres et les regarder les observer
et à s'adapter je pense que ça c'est
important quand on recherche un emploi
au japon à savoir qui sont les
résultants dans l'armée parce qu'ils
sont très en avant dire ouais on peut
faire ça on peut faire ça donc c'est
très bien parce que bah ça peut nous
aider pour les stratégies tout sonne que
j'ai un peut repérer dans l'après-midi
les masques tombent les recruteurs et
les candidats sont identifiés pour eux
un seul objectif trouver la nouvelle
recrue pour les entreprises où le
travail recherché pour les demandeurs
d'emploi et ainsi réaliser un grand
chelem de l'emploi